bonjour bernard caïazzo merci de
répondre à nos questions votre
association fait donc partie des
signataires et vous vous appuyez donc
sur le rapport publié en décembre 2010 9
qui pointe des sanctions trop tardif
pour des faits d'agression sexuelle
notamment
c'est quelque chose qui est trop
fréquent c'est ça oui tout à fait alors
le rapport de la cour des comptes qui il
s'attaque à différents pas de l'activité
des médecins malversations financières
abus de pouvoir favoritisme etc
mais où ça devient quand même très très
éclairant seller le traitement des
plaintes à caractère sexuel ou les
agresseurs sont des médecins il y en a
une conclusion de la cour des comptes se
basant sur une douzaine de dossiers qui
est accablante est unique il ya eu
l'ouverture de certains médecins
prédateurs sexuels
parlons des médecins et qui dans le même
temps à négliger les plaintes des
victimes qu'elle soit la plupart du
temps majeur mais aussi mineur comme on
va le revivre avec le nouveau procès de
la sphère joël le scouarnec quel sens
que votre demande aboutisse écoutez nous
nous que notre tribune là on a on l'a
lancée à trois organisations de
professionnels rejoints rapidement par
deux autres et qu'on se retrouve le très
rapidement 26 organisations avaient des
associations de la société civile etc et
qui sont interpellés parce que le poème
de l'ordre des médecins ça devient plus
et sa nocivité ce n'est plus une
question seulement pour des
professionnels
si un problème de santé publique c'est
un problème de société
dans le débat actuel sur les agressions
sexuelles les viols etc où on s'aperçoit
qu'une institution telle que l'ordre des
médecins protège des grandes prédateurs
1 et on n'a qu'une petite partie de la
face immergée de l'ordre dans je crois
qu'il faut un complément d'enquêté ce
rapport de la cour des comptes est
malheureux dans tous les dossiers qu'on
reçoit en dehors aussi d'aider preuve
d'agression sexuelle quand il s'agit de
maltraitance hameçons des choses comme
ça il ya une pédopsychiatre à toulouse
qui se voit interdite de trois mois de
l'exercer
non là c'est un peu plus dur et on
s'écrit alors vous en appelez au
gouvernement au premier ministre jean
castex au ministre de la santé olivier
ferrand ou même à d'autres ministères
qu'est ce que vous attendez
si vous voulez on en appelle aux
différents responsables pour qu'ils ne
maintiennent pas les choses en l'état
il ya trop à faire qui sont sentis il
faut que l'institution rendent des
comptes et à partir du diagnostic
partagé que l'on a mais qui est
accablant aux yeux de la cour des
comptes obéit il faudra un traitement
approprié si je pense est il utilisé ce
terme médical
mais si vous appelez à dissoudre l'ordre
des médecins que proposez vous à la
place écoutez on a des tas de réflexion
ancien 1 équivaut à être actualisée sur
les alternatives à l'ordre des médecins
on s'aperçoit que la plupart des
fonctions qui lui sont actuellement
attribués sont la plupart du temps
assuré ailleurs et que celle qui la
spécificité sont nocives
la juridiction d'exception c'est quelque
chose qui ne doit plus dure est la
plupart des victimes d'agressions
sexuelles s'adresse d'abord à l'ordre
bon on les alertes d'emblée et on dit
justice saisissez la justice commune
dont confirme travail à notre avis de
salubrité publique et après on a
beaucoup d'idées de propositions à faire
sur le devenir de leurs aînés de saint
qui est diane qui veut qu'il y ait une
partie des médecins qui veulent
constituer une association qui s'appelle
ordre qui respecte la liberté
associative qui respecte la vie la
séparation des pouvoirs et cetera tout à
fait d'accord mais quand il s'agit de
déterminer par exemple une déontologie
quel est le bon comportement pour les
professionnels ont dit qu'une
institution où il ya que des médecins et
qui défend des principes mais dépassé de
confraternité 1 c'est-à-dire qui amène à
une certaine omerta professionnels un
certain communautarisme
ça c'est à revoir à la lumière des
débats actuels sur le conforter nos
valeurs républicaines sur réforme du
système judiciaire etc
je veux des ans ne fait pas que
critiquer on aura beaucoup de
propositions à faire mais ce qu'on dit
c'est les choses ne peuvent rester en
l'état
l'ordre des médecins doit rendre des
comptes
vous dites avec les autres cosignataires
dans le document que vous signez que
l'ordre des médecins n'est pas
réformable c'est à dire non c'est à dire
c'est une
c'est un problème systémique le rapport
de la cour des comptes qui nous étonner
bien que nous en connaissons
l'institution mais qui a mis en exergue
et à la grande lumière un certain nombre
de fonctionnement on s'aperçoit que ce
sont des failles systémiques qui ne
peuvent pas être résolus quand moi si
j'amène de nouveaux éléments sur la
sphère le scouarnec qu'on va retrouver
dans les semaines et les mois qui
viennent y compris qu'ils vont aider la
justice à attentes ses décisions et ses
jeux peut être attaqué par les médecins
pour rupture de la confraternité
vis-à-vis de monsieur le scouarnec
donc je veux dire non ça ne peut pas
durer
nous on veut avoir les valeurs
républicaines qui s'exerce à nouveau
avec la non assistance en personne en
danger la défense de la liberté
d'exercice était là mais il ya des
choses à il ya des choses à dépoussiérer
canton mal an des médecins sur le procès
le scouarnec après l'avoir protégé la
justice va vraiment le dire se faire
connaître en partie civile se retrouve
auprès des victimes soit disant pour
défendre l'image de la profession
sadi part je vois le scouarnec ben c'est
masquer que l'institution elle a
participé un peu
malheureusement à la continuité des
pratiques de monsieur le scouarnec
donc je je veux dire avec la lumière
accolades de ces derniers mois non là il
ya ya ya ya ya quelque chose qui ne peut
pas durer un mois bon vous comprenez un
petit peu ma colère ma révolte mais je
le dis de manière tout à fait calme je
suis pratiquement persuadé qu'elles que
soient l'oeuvre des lobbys etc et des
attitudes de politicienne je crois que
les choses ne peuvent pas continuer
quelqu'un merci d'avoir répondu à une
question bernard cadiot
quad ou je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général de l'association m i
hope et le mouvement d'insoumission aux
ordres professionnels